ah
érase una vez un tiempo en el que parece
que nuestro consentimiento servía para
algo hoy parece que no sirve para nada
voy a intentar explicar los por qué
año 1946 en los juicios de nuremberg se
exige responsabilidad los mandatarios
nazis en lo que aquí interesa por los
experimentos realizados sobre cientos de
miles de prisioneros en los campos de
concentración
como resultado del veredicto de este
juicio se estableció el código núremberg
diez principios que debían cumplirse por
cualquier investigación que tuvieran por
objetos seres humanos para ser
considerada legítima el primero de sus
principios era obtener el consentimiento
informado del sujeto en el año 1973 se
descubrió que en alabama en el polo de
taxqueña los servicios públicos de salud
habían desarrollado una investigación
sobre 600 ciudadanos de raza negra se
les dijo que se les trataría la sífilis
pero en realidad no se les dispensó
medicamento ni tratamiento de ningún
tipo únicamente se observaba cómo
avanzaba la enfermedad
durante este tiempo se descubrió que la
penicilina curaba la enfermedad pero
tampoco se les dispensó algunos de estos
sujetos murieron
para evitar todo esto se desarrolló el
consentimiento informado y el concepto
originario el primigenio era suministrar
información relevante y comprensible al
sujeto sobre los efectos que tendría
para el participar en un procedimiento
estos textos se hicieron cada vez más
largos cada día sin más incomprensibles
y sobre todo cada vez más
desequilibrados empezaron a atender no
tanto a dar información al sujeto sino
sobre todo a limitar la responsabilidad
de la entidad que los presentaba este
concepto adulterado del consentimiento
informado fue el que pasó a los
contratos de licencia de software acepte
nuestros términos y condiciones antes de
instalar nuestro por nuestro software y
de aquí pasó a las aplicaciones de las
redes sociales que todos conocemos hoy
hoy en día estamos acostumbrados a
consentir términos y condiciones que no
leemos y que si leemos no comprendemos y
nos han hecho pensar que esto es lícito
pero no es así la familia de la doctora
ann cavoukian huyó del genocidio armenio
perpetrado en turquía egipto y de egipto
a canadá
la doctora anne que buscan conoce
perfectamente la diferencia o la
importancia hasta de vida o muerte de
mantener confidencial determinados datos
por ejemplo ser armenios o por ejemplo
ser judío
ha dedicado su vida a la defensa de la
privacidad en el año 2000 publicó su
estándar privacy by design privacidad es
del diseño uno de los principios del pri
base by design es detectar el truquito
de la balanza
normalmente se nos presenta en uno de
los dos platillos de una imaginaria
balanza el valor de la privacidad
opuesto a otro y se nos hace elegir
entre los dos por ejemplo se nos dice
tenemos que elegir entre nuestra
seguridad y nuestra privacidad tenemos
que elegir entre el progreso tecnológico
y nuestra privacidad tenemos que elegir
entre ganar dinero con nuestra
aplicación o mantener confidenciales los
datos de nuestros usuarios el standard
privacy by design nos enseña que tenemos
que conseguir los dos valores a la vez y
que solamente si solamente conseguimos
uno de ellos lo estamos haciendo mal y
tenemos que volver a empezar
el reglamento europeo de protección de
datos que entró en vigor en mayo del
2018 consagra y hace obligatorio el
estándar de la privacidad desde el
diseño y consagra y hace obligatorio el
consentimiento informado
pero en su sentido primigenio en el
originario en el que les explicado al
principio
esta normativa creo que es una de las
más decisivas de nuestro futuro y no
hace falta que les diga que es una de
las más incumplidas en nuestro presente
año 2009
mi amigo marc zuckerberg el consejo
delegado de facebook intenta hacernos el
truquito de la balanza dijo para
justificar que desde ese momento la
plataforma iba a hacer públicos los
datos básicos de identificación de todos
sus usuarios
en lugar de mantenerlos privados por
defecto como mandaría el pregase by
design dijo la privacidad ya no es una
norma social la privacidad ha muerto y
además no soy yo que le privó de sus
derechos son ustedes los que han
renunciado a ellas en realidad estaba
diciendo elijan ustedes entre utilizar
facebook y su privacidad elijan ustedes
entre subirse al carro del proceso
tecnológico o su privacidad bien
marc marc márque 10 añitos después la
foto ha cambiado y el mensaje ha
cambiado ahora este señor dice que el
futuro es privado y no es que se haya
vuelto bueno de repente es que 2018 fue
el peor año imaginable para facebook ha
perdido 15 millones de usuarios en su
plataforma de eeuu le han caído multas
hasta el carnet identidad ha perdido
completamente su reputación facebook es
uno de los principales vampiros de datos
que existen pero hay más y su número
aumenta día a día
estamos acostumbrados a interactuar con
aplicaciones que no están diseñadas para
mantener nuestros datos confidenciales
ni privados están diseñadas para ser
adictivas para mantenernos enganchados a
ellas y así poder engullir todos los
datos de los que sean capaces y además
tenemos cerquita para poder influir nos
y no es un problema de tecnología es un
problema de su uso sin escrúpulos
algunas de estas empresas están creando
una economía creciente basada en tres
ejes el expolio masivo de nuestros datos
personales y no personales la creación
con ellos de bases detalladísimas de
perfiles en las que estamos todos
metidos y el monopolio de una tecnología
punta necesaria para realizar estas
bases y monetizar las sacarles provecho
económico algunas de estas empresas
empiezan a ser capaces de saber lo que
queremos y lo que pensamos en algunos
casos mejor que nosotros pero lo
realmente peligroso para nuestros
derechos y libertades es que están
empezando a ser capaces de modificar lo
que pensamos y lo que queremos sin que
nos demos cuenta y esto no es una idea
que haya salido está calva calenturienta
sudorosa y ensangrentada no
hay gente que sabe mucho más que yo de
esto cómo se sana su voz o como giovanni
butarelli que dice lo mismo pero os voy
a poner un ejemplo que todos ustedes
conocen y que ya ha ocurrido
en 2018 está hay un escándalo que
involucraba a dos grandes vampiros de
datos facebook y cambridge analítica 87
millones de personas pensaban que
estaban compartiendo sus fotografías sus
experiencias y sus chorradas diarias en
la plataforma y en realidad eran como
conejillos de indias en un experimento
como el de alabama pero mucho más grande
estaban entregando un algoritmo que en
definitiva sirvió para adulterar el
resultado del referéndum por el brete en
el reino unido
pongamos las cosas en contexto
la tecnología ya había contribuido a la
victoria de barack obama en 2008 y en
2012 y por ejemplo en españa a la de
mariano rajoy en 2015 pero lo del break
sí fue una cosa completamente distinta
no solamente se utiliza una tecnología
apunta mucho más avanzada que también
sobre todo la diferencia estuvo en su
uso sin escrúpulos se captaron y
manipularon datos de más de 87 millones
de personas entre ellos 140 mil
españoles se enviaron miles de mensajes
personalizados de contenido inexacto o
directamente falso no sé si han oído a
ustedes a hablar de las facebook
como guinda del pastel parece que toda
la campaña fue financiada ilegalmente
me quedo con la magnitud con la escala
del desastre que no hubiera pensado
antes del ver sí que sería posible
manipular el resultado de un proceso
electoral únicamente con la tecnología
en la casa de mis suegros y
concretamente en el baño ocurren cosas
maravillosas es un lugar mágico ahí se
me han ocurrido algunas de mis mejores
ideas
y por ejemplo se me ocurrió
la idea de la lista viernes junto con
mis compañeros de cuéllar ideamos
desarrollamos financiamos y propagamos
la lista viernes y les cuento que es hay
una cosa que se llama la lista robinson
que es una lista a la que tú te apuntas
para que no te llamen a la hora de la
siesta intentando convencerte de que te
cambios de compañía telefónica sé que a
ustedes esto no les ha pasado pero se
han dado casos
la lista robinson la hicimos a imagen y
semejanza de esa y queríamos que la
gente se apuntará ahí para lanzar el
mensaje los partidos políticos de que no
queríamos que nos enviaran publicidad
electoral y esto venía a cuento porque a
raíz del requisito alguien pensó que
podía pasar lo mismo en españa' que una
cosa parecida a la que en dicha
analítica podría pasar en españa aquí
viene la afirmación más increíble de
toda esta charla por primera vez en 10
años todos los partidos políticos
españoles se pusieron de acuerdo en una
cosa decidieron reformar la ley
electoral y aprobar un artículo el 58
bis el artículo 58 bis permitiría a los
partidos políticos fundamentalmente dos
cosas recopilar los datos personales de
todos los ciudadanos para clasificar les
ideológicamente y además captar nuestros
datos de internet para sus fines
electorales
en concreto para enviarnos publicidad
online
todo esto sin nuestro consentimiento y
sin ningún tipo de garantía
en realidad paradójicamente el 58 bis
tenía por objetivo impedir que
ocurrieron que el vix analítica en
españa- pero lo que pasaba con este
artículo puesto encima de la mesa era
que el cambridge analítica español era
no solamente posible sino perfectamente
lícito muchos juristas denunciamos este
artículo 58 bis
conseguimos que la polémica llegara a
los medios de comunicación después de
semanas como digo yo igual todos los
partidos políticos por unanimidad
consiguieron aprobar el artículo 58 bis
e incorporarlos a nuestro ordenamiento
jurídico
nuestra lista viernes no tuvo mucho
éxito nosotros pensábamos que tendríamos
que tener unos 500 mil o un millón de
usuarios para que funcionara bien pero
sólo alcanzamos 6000 en realidad lo que
pensamos es que nuestra vista viene será
la solución a un problema que no llegó a
darse las reelecciones que tuvimos en
mayo los partidos políticos no se
atrevieron a hacer las marranadas que se
habían hecho en el break sito la agencia
protección datos hizo un trabajo
estupendo publicó una circular y trazó
unas líneas rojas que no debían ser
transgredidas o infringidas por los
partidos políticos y anuncios que
castigaría con contundencia a los que se
atrevieron a hacerlo al final y el
objetivo por cumplido porque al final no
pasó nada raro mientras preparábamos la
vista viernes me llamó mi amigo por
fuera y me ofreció participar en el
borrador de un recurso de
inconstitucionalidad contra el artículo
58 bis a mí al principio aquello no me
pareció muy buena idea porque yo no sé
mucho derecho constitucional yo de lo
que es de derecho societario y de
protección de datos y no mucho pero ese
fin de semana yo estaba en casa de mis
suegros y en esa ducha mágica en esa
ducha mágica dije que leches en realidad
hice otra cosa pero creo que no cumplen
las normas te estás
siete bocados estuvimos trabajando
gratis los fines de semana y por las
noches ahora que lo estoy pensando esta
afirmación es mucho más increíble que
los partidos políticos poniéndose de
acuerdo
y preparamos un borrador de recursos de
constitución de la articulación cuenta y
8 bis hubo otras plataformas como otros
borradores todos los entregamos al
defensor del pueblo y el defensor del
pueblo presentó su recurso ante el
tribunal constitucional tres meses
después el tribunal constitucional
declaró nulo e inconstitucional el
apartado primero del artículo 58 bis en
que permite a los partidos políticos
clasificarnos conforme a nuestra
ideología
ese día creo que ganamos todos ese día
fue una victoria ciudadana fantástica y
esto demuestra que hay soluciones pero
hay que utilizarlas para corregir las
cosas injustas y para denunciar las el
día que se publicó la sentencia para mí
fue un día muy peliculero como dice tom
hanks en filadelfia a veces muy de tarde
en tarde pero alguna vez un abogado
tiene la oportunidad de participar en el
hecho de que se haga justicia y cuando
sucede es emocionante para mí es
emocionante decir que en españa en este
país ya tenemos una cierta tradición en
la reivindicación y consecución de
derechos digitales
esta luz del 58 bits que también pero
sobre todo está lo del derecho al olvido
en el año 2012 90 ciudadanos españoles
habían exigido a google que retirara de
los resultados de sus búsquedas
determinados datos que les perjudicaban
y que ya resultaban irrelevantes porque
eran antiguos o por cualquier otra razón
google se negó el asunto llegó al
tribunal europeo de justicia y en 2014
este tribunal dictó la gloriosa
histórica sentencia google spain
reconociendo consagrando el derecho al
olvido
déjeme que ponga en valor el derecho al
olvido el derecho al olvido es el gol de
iniesta en la final de la copa del mundo
de la protección de datos personales el
derecho al olvido es la mayor patada que
se han llevado google y facebook en sus
pelotas vampíricas y la bota que dio esa
patada fue una bota española hoy en día
vivimos en un experimento como el de
alabama pero de dimensiones planetarias
facebook tiene más de 2 mil millones de
usuarios más del 90% de las búsquedas
que se hacen en internet se hacen a
través de google no podemos permitir que
estas empresas se porten como vampiros
necesitamos que cumplan la ley
necesitamos que cumplan normativas de
protección de datos personales la
normativa de protección del consumidor
la normativa antimonopolio que pagarán
sus impuestos no estaría nada mal todos
los medios legales son lentos llegarán
pero tardarán pero hay una cosita la
normativa prevé también una sanción muy
eficaz contra los vampiros de datos
prevé la posibilidad de limitarles o
impedirles el uso de nuestros datos
y lo bueno que tiene estas medidas que
no tenemos que esperar que le imponga
ninguna autoridad nosotros solitos
podemos hacerlo podemos poner a los
vampiros de datos a dieta de datos
podemos exigir el borrado de nuestros
datos periódicamente a las plataformas
que se porten como vampiros ejerciendo
el derecho de supresión que los
españoles consiguieron y regalaron
gloriosamente al mundo porque no tenemos
que elegir entre su servicio y nuestra
privacidad tenemos derecho a las dos
cosas al mismo tiempo porque tenemos
derecho a que nuestra información y
nuestros datos sólo se ha tratado en
formas que nos hayan informado que
hayamos comprendido y que hayamos
consentido pero de verdad de la buena
creo que esta lucha merece la pena ser
luchado y creo que no la ganaremos
mañana y creo que no será fácil pero
creo que podemos ganarla juntos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]